oh my god don't take anything I don't
believe anything don't believe anything
there is a woman fighting for her life
in a hospital in Arizona tonight her
husband died because they took
chloroquine after hearing the president
say it was the right way to treat their
Kovan 19 illness according to this guy's
widow he kept seeing Trump and people
around from say this could cure
coronavirus this could prevent
coronavirus so the 68 year old went out
and got chloroquine phosphate he thought
it was the medication chloroquine an
Arizona couple unfortunately made the
mistake of taking a drug that's known as
chloroquine because they heard Donald
Trump talking about how it's a possible
treatment for coronavirus now tragically
this couple living in Arizona really did
suffer the consequences of listening to
someone who has no medical expertise
this is the danger of saying things and
announcing treatments announcing
medicines when they haven't been proven
when there are people in the public who
won't fully understand the nuances
they're not doctors they don't know she
talks about how she really trusted Trump
and encourages people to avoid doing
that we've been saying from talking
about chloroquine like it's a game
changer can only cause problems it's not
going to create any solutions and right
away we have one such example
everyone remembers the lady who drank
fish tank leader right yes koi pond
cleaner
I didn't say pulley oh boy pond cleaner
yeah you're gonna story that we heard
right the story that we all heard and
was covered in most major news outlets
both on television and publications was
that she heard a press briefing from
Donald Trump touting the benefits of
chloroquine medications medications
drive by a doctor therefore because she
trusted everything Donald Trump said she
and her husband they both drank it and
he died unfortunately a tragedy she
didn't and then she had some words on
mainstream media for everyone else this
was the story this is how it was covered
let's go to the clip
did you see the president's press
conference where did you hear about and
then what and then what did you did you
seek out clean okay so here's the thing
some of this is absolutely 100% true
that we have and then I will offer my
opinion okay the truth is we know that
it's a sham that she hates president
Donald Trump right so at the very least
this was a fake story on that front so
you probably already know and I am going
to be looking down to make sure they get
this correctly she was obviously a
prolific Democrat don't her she donated
to Hillary Clinton in 2016 we were able
to confirm her identity and these
reports okay this has been released
publicly something I haven't seen
covered anywhere else though I don't
know that nowhere else has covered it
she specifically donated to nonprofits
that were a progressive sort of science
nonprofits basically if you read their
mission statement it was the agenda the
mission was to counteract the anti
science agenda the anti medicine agenda
of the conservative right I thought it
was to make clear you know that what you
don't know okay and is exclusive here
the same woman I think we have an
overlay here on
social media called President Trump a
psycho Prez okay she called him a psycho
president she has a history of violent
behavior okay
so this idea it's bad this idea is you
know you're picturing her the media has
presented her as a pro Trump middle
American right now she just trusted
Trump and her and her husband were
drinking fish tank cleaner holding each
other like a couple in Titanic
yeah when the truth is she wanted to
divorce her husband okay so when she was
discussing divorcing her husband in 2001
she attacked him was arrested was
charged with domestic abuse assault
though eventually she was found not
guilty she still talked about wanting to
divorce him in 2012 and said quote I am
furious all the time
she reiterated it in a 2013 court case
now some of this has been tweeted out
okay some of this information has been
tweeted out but we were able to confirm
some of these other sources with two
separate two other these other claims of
two separate sources okay one of them
being a lawsuit that people sort of
covered but they missed the assault case
where she filed against a company I
believe it was John Deere tractor where
she worked for before I don't know why
exactly why she sued them but that's
where the assault was mentioned because
her real name wasn't used in any of the
stories there we go okay and then the
other one is we have some exclusive
access to social media and I had this
corroborated with some folks in law
enforcement I looked it up so she filed
for chapter I know when she felt for
bankruptcy some information that's not
necessarily relevant but it did serve to
confirm this case now here's the deal we
made sure to try and redact all the
names I obviously don't want to Doc's
anyone so please nobody out there try
and Docs or figure anything out but the
media knows this woman's name yeah so
they went out and they didn't cover her
name they just covered the story this
lady who who was a president Trump
supporter drank fish tank cleaner
because Donald Trump is is praising an
unverified unproven a non-antibiotic
what is it I guess an anti virals some
ever be on TV right yeah he's been he's
been basically touting the benefits of
this anti coronavirus drug the story was
poor old lady and husband who love each
other and love Trump died the media
meaning New York Times ABC NBC by the
way I'm going to be calling everything
one of them after the show so I want you
to send in numbers heads of News people
who you think would be in charge of
these stories or who ran these stories
because they knew this woman's name yeah
they claimed they were withholding it
due to you know wanting to keep her
anonymous in which case they knew that
she wanted to divorce her husband they
knew that she hated President Donald
Trump and they knew that at least part
of this was a shame and that is
journalistic malpractice or ABC NBC CBS
all of these major news outlets
Washington Post didn't know her name in
which case you did not verify or vet
your anonymous source which is
journalistic malpractice and you did
this to try and alter the face of an
election by the way because that's in
the central issue that Donald Trump
hasn't handled this properly and this
was a linchpin for a lot of it he's
going out there making here's Donald
Trump anti-science again and you found a
woman who gave the hillary clinton and
gave to conservatives are anti science
nonprofits and something else okay so
all of this we know beyond any shadow of
a doubt right now was a sham to try and
harm the president and by proxy all
conservatives but but do you know what
else this means this is speculation this
is speculation I think this is the new
Carole Baskin husband long history of it
she wanted to divorce him she clearly
hated Trump and only her husband died
and didn't realize it was mixed with a
little bit of koi food last week you
guys remember that we revealed this to
chloroquine Lee the ladies and rank fish
tank cleaner okay the lady who drank
fish the senator and said she drank fish
things that her husband most definitely
drank fish tank cleaner her husband died
right and she gave the interview go back
and watch it where she said we took it
because we trusted Trump and don't
nobody else should ever do the same well
that we went through that was a story
you were told there were some publicly
available information but the media was
not interested in it that she was a
prolific Democratic donor that she hated
Donald Trump this was well documented
and that she had history of mental
illness and violent outbursts what was
exclusive to us is that we found the
court case where she was charged
ultimately found not guilty but charged
with domestic assault and there were
several different occasions where she
wanted to divorce her husband and said
that she was angry all the time so
we thought that this might be relevant
to the original reporters at NBC they
co-wrote this story and we called them
offering the evidence
this lady is there were there was Vaughn
I can't member his name in an Erica
Erica what was the hospital it works
Eric Edwards they co-wrote the original
article yes you can find it you see if
you search this and you go back to the
original article this is the one that
was shared like a virus across all other
mainstream outlets so we tried to go
directly to the source and see if the
media wanted to do the journalism that
their journalistic jobs typically entail
sounds logical and my half-asian Larry
Villiers mr. let's play the audio if we
have it hi Erika Edwards steven crowder
calling how are you good thank you so
much I'm so sorry that I missed your
call um do you have a minute well I'm
calling because I'm actually writing a
story here and I have some some
information from an anonymous source
that I want to keep anonymous and I know
that you guys over there obviously
discretion is pretty important it's
regarding the woman who drank the fish
tank cleaner the chloroquine which I I
believe I was trying to find who wrote
it I believe you co-wrote it with Vaughn
Hilliard yeah so right now I'm actually
calling from just so you know I said I'm
calling from from [ __ ] ville I knew that
was a bad sign continue you don't laugh
at [ __ ] ville yes yes I'm a freelancer
and in you know again I I know it's I've
done something a leader and I know it's
important to keep her obviously
anonymous I mean I'm assuming you you
know the person in question who you who
you wrote about sorry I should ask that
first okay so you did write the story
and you are aware that it's a it's great
so I wanted to ask you this I've come
upon some information you're doing some
digging the story originally that was
published
you know stated that she drank fish tank
cleaner and obviously sadly her husband
died and
an interview that was posted where she
said she did it because she saw it from
a trump press conference correct yeah
okay and then she did say that she
trusted him and that no one should
should do the same I have the article up
right here I've wanted to know since you
know were you aware of the fact that she
was a you must be a prolific Democratic
donor and berry did you you guys you
know her name and obviously it's public
record most people don't have a name
because I understand it's anonymous and
rightfully so I hate her name but I know
you didn't say your name but I'm just
saying I know her name I was just
confirming that way I'm not letting the
cat out of the bag so you know the woman
in question and obviously you guys do do
great journalism there at NBC News so I
wanted to know if if you had discovered
if you came upon this information or can
confirm that she's a Democratic donor
who gave to Hillary in 2016 and
repeatedly throughout her yeah I don't
know any I don't know anything that's
not even relevant to the story quite
frankly isn't it relevant because she
said that she did it because Trump told
her to and there are multiple sources
here that show she was violently anti
Trump as an activist for a long time so
it seems peculiar that she would all of
a sudden decide to take medical advice
from Donald Trump when she also gave to
pro science anti right-wing anti science
ideology as it stated here nonprofits
okay mean is do you have a question for
me or I mean that sounds like it's your
story well I am asking if you knew this
when you posted his story because it
seemed like it would be pretty relevant
know that someone went out there saying
no one should trust President Trump I
think no see I think that you did I
think that either you didn't do your due
diligence also let me move on here are
you aware about the assault case with
her husband that she mentioned divorcing
her husband because this is a totally
separate instance here we're not talking
about politics but she openly wanted to
divorce her husband and we found the
court documents of her being charged
with assault
against her husband who died from
drinking the fish tank cleaner were you
aware of that i I think that you have a
story there that you should go with
that'sthat's not go let me ask since you
published the original story would you
be willing to correct the story since
this is relevant information do you not
see it as relevant information that a
woman who went out saying she did
something because she was a supporter of
Trump when we know that she's not and
she could see her husband I have the
evidence I can send it to you would that
would that be irrelevant would you like
to care I don't have a big news outlet
that's the thing I have this information
I have corroborated it 100% with
authorities I would love to get it to
you because I would love to see the
truth get out here because as we know as
journalists is very important take it I
don't I don't want the credit I just
want to make sure the truth is out there
and I can send you all of this evidence
if you would I think that you have a
story to tell and I wish you good luck I
think you have the truth to tell here
and I would like to provide it to you
NBC News
do you understand that this is the
definition of a fake news at this point
I can provide you evidence right now
that she was by the way it should be
noted we sent this email I think we have
a screen shot to both her and the
co-writer with verification
corroboration of the evidence and no
responsible they're working sounds to me
like you have a story to tell um sounds
to me like you have a retraction too
right yeah there was an interesting
response I don't see how I drove into
the story hold on a second you ran a
story where a lady this is what's so
remarkable to me you ran a story where a
lady a man died because him and his wife
trusted Donald Trump and drank fish tank
cleaner turns out they don't like Donald
Trump at all and she hated her husband
yeah that's pretty relevant this woman
who was actually pretty she it it looked
good little two-for-one go in there she
not only got rid of the husband she
didn't want to have in the first place
and she got to stick it can we say that
that speculation killed her husband yeah
sure I mean she is the Carol but if a
Terrell matter
to look into it
yes call him from prison and see if we
can have you heard about the fish tank
cleaner lady he's like I know I think so
I wouldn't be surprised you know and
here's the thing I don't know how that
necessarily works as far as some kind of
an investigation separate from the
separate from the news side of it yeah
because this would be something that
would we have to would someone have to
report that to local authorities it
seems like it would be more of a
national kind of investigation concerned
that involves donations a long-standing
history with I mean the donations aren't
a crime no no they're not a crime but
it's something that involves national
elections where it's not like the
evidence presented isn't just well she
was she was horrible at the local
supermarkets like no she tried to
influence elections for a long time and
she hated her husband no I mean
influencing elections is literally what
everyone does whether they're trying to
hurt I don't typically off their husband
put the crime the crime itself is the
crime itself right it's the same reason
why there's no like why you know there's
just significant argument against having
hate crimes it's because the crime
itself is the crime right as opposed to
necessarily the reasons behind it in
local authorities though like access her
how would one report it well they have
to report to the local police department
you can report it to any of them and
then they'll sort it out amongst
themselves might be investigating it
right now and we're just not hearing you
about it well we're definitely hearing
about it as long as erica has to be
doing her job
well yes right I just can't imagine this
is the reason when people don't trust
the media this is exactly why like this
isn't an example of me I didn't we
didn't call it aggressively going here
are you crazy you know just going like
hey this is relevant would you like this
sounds to me like you have a story
yeah sounds to me like you had a story
someone came in and said and here's the
crazy thing think about this is it could
there be anything more catnip e to
reporters than a salacious story of a
woman who potentially offed her husband
yes yes yes yes if Donald Trump offed
her husband and that is the story that
decided to run with the only thing more
appealing than Jo tiger and Carol Baskin
or making a murderer is if said murderer
can be implicated as president Trump
remember the the chloroquine the fish
tank cleaner lady and we said that she
actually hated Donald Trump she hated
her husband exposed and she knew that it
was not chloroquine it was fish tank
cleaner and then we called the NBC
reporter who was you know quart sort of
the original source for this we said you
know what I think this woman's new Karel
Baskin to point someone should run an
investigation into this broad well guess
what now it's happening cleaner lady
being investigated for homicide one and
we called it early early early on all of
us were like sounds a little weird well
it turned out now the husband so sheets
to be clear to recap she said that she
drank fish tank cleaner her and her
husband they drank it together like a
Romeo and Juliet realizes yeah yeah only
it was really just was really just if
Juliet said okay Romeo down the gullet
cleaners good fish tank right behind ya
drink my in just a minute and then John
Leguizamo is speaking in Shakespearean
was he you me I was heating them Romeo
and Juliet with slavery Canada I don't
think so it was terrible
but so that so she the original Stroh
was she loves Donald Trump's so she
trusted Donald Trump and they both drank
fished and clean and her husband
unfortunately died and no one else
should trust Donald Trump we did some
digging
turns out she hates Donald Trump she's
an anti-trump activists she's donated to
Democrats and she actually hated her
husband she has a history of a domestic
abuse she was charged for that she has a
history of violence she has a history of
mental health disorders and now we know
that her husband turns out was actually
a really smart engineer now you know
dumb guy you would assume if she's a
drink this fish tank cleaner he'd have a
couple questions yeah it's like now I
just want to make sure is this one of
those moments where you love me or yeah
exactly you know it also could just be
might investigating find out it was a
suicide she's like hey do you want to
drink this yes my will is giving it all
to charity like a Warren Buffett you get
nothing
oh so he was an engineer yeah and now
they're investigating it for homicide
well what's funny is that all we were
doing was really digging into this to
prove a point like this person didn't do
this because of Donald Trump like that
would that was the story
I'm joking I was half joking and now I
like no thank you
very very prophetic did you have
anything else on the I thought you're
bringing up the art well I have the
article in here but a whole lot of
information right now the Mesa City
Police Department they are investigating
it they're just saying that they can't
say anything right now because it is an
ongoing investigation and so that means
like okay this isn't that they're just
like taking a kind of a quick look at it
they've actually opened an investigation
into this and so I guarantee we're gonna
find out something shady went down here
yeah we didn't know a whole lot about it
and you know what again these are the
same things that that reporter could
have done or you like 75 other outlets
right now we're like hey if you enjoyed
this video subscribe or hit the
notification bell and hit all
notifications because not all
notifications work now just at the
normal notification Bell I think there's
some videos playing in boxes but of
course you consider subscribing at
ladder of credit comm / mug Club because
there's a bunch of content that could
never make it onto YouTube and I think
the box is playing there's a video
playing in a box with